An offer that is unequivocally accepted,
creates a contract,
but what happens when an offer?
He attempts to accept an offer while modifying the terms.
Today we consider that question and learn about the mirror image rule.
By looking at the 1886 case decided by the United States Supreme Court called
Minneapolis and Saint Louis Railway Company versus Columbus Rolling Mill Company
in Minneapolis and Saint Louis Railway.
The plaintiff,
a railroad company,
sent a letter dated December 5th two the defendant,
a manufacturer requesting price quotes for steel rails.
The letter asked for the prices for 500 to 3000 tons of steel rails and 2000 to
5,000 tons of iron rails.
The defendant manufacturer replied on December 8th writing that it did not make
steel rails but would sell 2000 to 5,000 tons of iron rails for $54 per gross
ton for cash.
On December 16th the railway company responded by telegram and followed up with
a second letter to accept the manufacturer's off offer for 1200 tons of iron
rails at the quoted price.
The manufacturer responded by telegram that he could not book the order at that
price.
The railway then sent a telegram accepting the offer to sell 2000 tons.
The manufacturer did not fill that order either and denied the existence of any
contract.
The trial court found for the defendant manufacturer and the instant court
affirmed.
So the central issue in this case is fairly straight forward.
Was the defendant bound to honor the plaintiff's final acceptance of the offer
to sell 2000 tons of iron rails?
And the answer is no.
The court agreed with the defendant and held that no contract was formed.
The defendant offered to sell 2000 to 5,000 tons of iron rail to the plaintiff.
The plaintiff then attempted to accept the offer by ordering just 1200 tons,
an amount less than the 2000 ton minimum offered.
The court held that quote,
a proposal to accept or an acceptance upon terms varying from those offered is a
rejection of the offer and puts an end to the negotiation unless the party who
made the original offer renews it or a sense to the modification suggested since
the plaintiffs qualified acceptance varied the number of tons it was in law,
our rejection of the offer,
the plaintiff subsequent attempt to accept the defendant's offer to sell 2000
tons of iron rails was therefore unenforceable because as the court put it,
the other party having once rejected the offer cannot afterward revive it by
tendering and acceptance to it.
The holding in Minneapolis and Saint Louis Railways is really a classic example
of the common law mirror image rule.
The mirror image rule operates with admirable simplicity.
Any response by an offeree,
which varies or adds to the terms of an offer,
is treated as a counteroffer.
In turn,
that counter offer terminates or blows up the original offer.
Traditionally,
courts have insisted upon a total congruent between the offer and acceptance.
In other words,
the acceptance must be the mirror image of the offer.
So here's a pop quiz.
Ben,
knowing Alex is looking to sell his car meets Alex at his home.
Alex offers to sell the car for $10,000 after kicking the tires a bit,
Ben Tells Alex,
I'll take the car with the new air freshener for $10,000 immediately after Ben
Finishes the sentence,
carry drives by,
leans out the window and shouts,
I'll take the car for $12,000 Alex then refuses to sell the car to Ben,
who is now willing to take the car as is without a new air freshener for $10,000
is Alex bound to sell the car to Ben?
No.
Ben's response that he would buy the car and a new air freshener vary the terms
of Alex's original offer.
Therefore,
under the mirror image rule,
it was not an acceptance.
It was a counter offer and thus a rejection that terminated the original offer.
Under the mirror image rule,
even a nonmaterial variation like an air freshener can be fatal.
Okay.
The assumption underlying the mirror image rule is that if the offeree
introduces new or different terms,
the offeree does not assent to the offer and further negotiation is required.
It would be clearly impermissible for an offeree buyer to accept an offer while
at the same time reducing the offer or a selling price,
but other less important terms are connected to the price.
Unilateral changes introduced by the offeree might change.
The offer is costs or risk.
The offer might agree to changes,
but that should be the offer wars choice an offer he cannot pick and choose from
among the terms agreeing here and disagreeing there and then assert the
existence of a mutual agreement.
However,
the mirror image rule has its downsides.
The mirror image rule makes it more difficult to create contracts because any
deviation by the offeree and restating the terms can destroy what otherwise
would be a validly formed contract.
Accepting by restating terms of the offer is dangerous because if you miss state
any of the terms you not only don't accept but you,
you're misstatement blows up the original offer and your option to accept is
gone.
That's why it's safer to accept by simply saying I accept or okay or done.
If a party wishes to negotiate a point,
he does so at his own peril because doing so will terminate the original offer
or if the party seemingly reach an agreement,
but one party later discovers that the acceptance that the acceptance differs
slightly from the offer.
The Mirror image rule provides that party with a route to withhold performance.
There are strong hints of the Mirror image rule in section 59 of the restatement
second of contracts which as a reply to an offer which purports to accept it but
is conditional on the offer or is sent to terms additional to or different from
those offered is not an acceptance but as a counteroffer.
The restatement however is a little more forgiving than the common law mirror
image rule under section 61 an offeree may request additional changes when she
accepts an offer.
Section 61 reads quote and acceptance which requests a change or addition to the
terms of an offer is not thereby and validated unless the acceptance is made to
depend on a sent to the changed or added terms.
So consider again the example above were Alex offers to sell his car to Ben for
10,000 this time instead of insisting on a new Air Freshener,
Ben Tells Alex you have a deal and I'd appreciate it if you could throw in a new
air freshener for good measure.
Under this scenario.
Can Alex revoke is a offer after Carrie drives by and offers $12,000 for the
car?
No.
Under section 61 of the restatement Ben is allowed to accept Alex his offer and
request a complimentary air fresher as long as this acceptance does not depend
on Alex providing the air freshener here.
Ben Explicitly accepted out cause his offer and did not seem to condition that
acceptance,
uh,
on his request for a new air freshener
under the common law.
The mirror image rule is a default rule which can be contracted around by either
the offer or or the offeree,
as described by section 39 sub part two of the restatement and offer.
His power of acceptance is terminated by his making a counter offer unless the
offer or has manifested a contrary intention or unless the counteroffer manifest
and contrary intention of the offeree,
in other words and offer or can specify that an offer is not terminated by a
counteroffer and an offeree can make a counteroffer without rejecting the
original offer.
Section 39 is unusual because it creates what might be called the double sided
default rule,
which can be unilaterally altered by either the offer or or the offeree.
Yeah.
Let's recap.
Today we discuss the mirror image rule,
which says that an offeree cannot accept an offer while simultaneously and
unilaterally changing the terms of the offer.
Introducing do terms creates a counteroffer and unless otherwise specified by
either of the parties,
a counteroffer destroys the original offer.